and we are joined tonight as you know by
Susie Boniface and Sebastian Payne
welcome to both of you we're going to
start with the mail and that headline
the mail usually supportive of a
conservative Administration how much
more can she and the rest of us take
Susie well they're not just supportive I
mean the mayor's doing an enormous
reverse ferret here because the mail
throughout the leadership campaign was
massively supportive of Liz pushed her
well ahead of all the other contenders
and in the last few weeks while she's
been facing these troubles and they've
been starting even after the budget they
lauded the budget as the best Tory
budget in recent history and it was it
was going to solve all our problems and
now they're saying we can't take anymore
they're actually calling her first
Thursday eight days in office have
proved some of the most shambolic and
British political history it's pretty
devastating right through on the front
page which won't make very happy reading
inside there tomorrow morning when she
wakes up no Sebastian especially coming
from the mail no and I just want to read
you the introduction from the males
piece tomorrow to give an idea was how
much of a reverse authorities you called
it Susie the male have done her first 38
days at office have proved some of the
most shambolic in British political
history and this is a newspaper that
fully backed Liz truss's leadership bid
that throughout everything we've seen
since she became prime minister just
over a month ago they've been Foursquare
behind and now they're essentially
saying the game is over and many of the
other newspapers tomorrow who are maybe
less supportive of let's just say that
as well we're coming from the mail that
just shows how much conservative opinion
behind Liz truss has collapsed in the
past 24 hours and the general mood in
Westminster tonight is not if Liz trust
goes it's when she goes and I think when
you've lost the mail you've lost the
Daily Telegraph you've lost MPS the only
people I think she's still got on her
side are her cabinet who have all been
quite supportive and tweetings for the
moment you know something that we don't
well no but if if they've been tweeting
support Sebastian Sesame putting out the
approved Graphics that they've been
handed by the Press office but when
people approach them and say when you go
on the record will you come to an
interview you go on television oh no
sorry I'm a bit busy I'm doing something
else so they're not supportive enough to
actually come out and defend it because
they know they can perhaps sense that
it's going to become indefensible well
we know someone who is going to support
it and that is the new Chancellor Jeremy
Hunt as you were saying Julian is doing
the broadcast rounds in the morning and
he's going to have to answer some very
big questions about the government's
economic strategy because as well as
replacing quasi quatang today the Prime
Minister has jumped half her economic
platform which was not just a budget it
was the whole purpose Liz trust exists
the reason that she occupies that black
door there and with her Economic Policy
gone what two emps are saying tonight
and it's reflected on many of the papers
is what's the point of the Liz trust
Administration if you're not going to do
this tax cutting dash for growth then
you're just existing and at the moment
it barely feels like she's doing that
let's go back to what what's been
happening today and obviously the
sacking of questi quateng is that that
the sole reason that you think the the
mood has changed
it's one of those things where she
didn't have any alternative either she
had to say the whole jig's up we're all
off or she had to make someone take the
blame for this so she she had no little
option but to fire him and it seems this
evening that he found out from seeing
reports in the times read it on Twitter
when his plane landed but Jeremy hunted
that she had a call at half past nine in
the morning well before um crazy even
knew he'd been sat and the times that
she was quoting or not quote but a
source close to Crazy saying that he
thinks that her firing him isn't going
to actually save her skin at all it's
going to buy her a few weeks but that's
it the wagons are circling and so it's
it's it just sort of extends things a
bit it doesn't actually save her because
even having got rid of him what what has
she done to show us so she's shown
herself disloyal she's shown herself
with Chris Gillen doing yet another
U-turn she's um showing herself trying
to Double Down publicly as we saw in
that press conference this afternoon but
yet still having to find a way to claw
back some of the things that she was
going to push for and in fact her her
decision to bring back that corporation
tax increase massive six percent on
business tax bills overnight even though
they've been expecting it for a while
businesses have also been expecting a
recession they're pulling their horns in
they're trying not to do any excess
spending to suddenly raise those taxes
as well is going to really Crush growth
that she says she's been going for and
like Sebastian says if she is actually
stopping growth with her policies what
is the point of a Liz trust and
Sebastian it's hardly a reset if she was
you know hand and glove with the the
ex-chancellor question in formulating
the economic policy she's just as
culpable as he is well the key thing in
his resignation letter which both of
them were quite an odd exchange of
letters when you looked at the tone and
the language used between the Prime
Minister and the former Chancellor
quasi-quartang made it very clear this
is your policy your strategy we did this
together and he said he was very sorry
to be asked to resign list trust in her
letter said she was sorry that he
decided to go so that two completely
different stories which normally you
don't see in those exchanges of letters
they normally stick to the same script
either you decide to go or you're pushed
out the door and the reason I think
quasi-quartang had to go was the market
they just did not believe that the
government's economic strategy was
credible and by the way they still don't
believe it because Liz trust gave
probably the most bizarre press
conference I've seen a prime minister
give today it was eight minutes long
actually came on stage gave a very brief
tour statement explaining that she was
still going on in the National interest
as she talked about it and then tried to
take questions to the media took four
questions and then just stormed off the
stage and walked out went back to
whatever she was doing before that did
not reassure markets and the fact is
that 60 billion pounds package that was
announced 20 billion pounds of it has
been pulled away but there's still 40
billion pounds that need to be answered
for and we've got no indication from the
chance from the new Chancellor Jeremy
Hunt and the Prime Minister how that's
going to be paid for and until they can
explore explain how the sums add up
which is going to be the junking the
rest of this mini budget or massive
spending cuts then the markets are not
going to trust this government so Jeremy
Hunt's got a huge Challenge on our hand
I would probably predict although no
one's really predict anything at the
moment we have not seen the last of the
u-turns even though Jeremy Hunt agree
with Liz trust there will be no more
u-turns
the guardian describing it as a day of
chaos and the press conference as you
say not very well received even
conservative back Ventures saying that
actually they felt that her performance
made everything worse or exactly if you
come out if you've got this kind of
situation you need to come out and
appear to be as honest and as open as
possible you take up questions from
everybody and you don't read off the
script in front of you as you're
responding you just you speak openly and
honestly and you say look we've made a
mistake it's classic crisis calm I'm
trying to do this right let me explain
things to you and we'll see where we go
from here kind of thing you do it
properly and she did it appallingly
badly considering she's got an entire
comms team in there advising her and
they must have been practicing for half
the day and she still came out and was
you know spent a lot of time looking
around the room trying to find a
friendly journalist friendly face so oh
someone's going to ask me a nice
question uh looked awful while she was
doing it picked someone who immediately
asked for a very hostile question
um and she's busy saying that you know
and it's been quoted everywhere she's
asked decisively she's been decisive
shaken decisive action but there's been
no thought before the decisions were
made and unfortunately despite the way
the markets have panicked and so on she
is doing to be fair to her exactly what
she said she was going to do in the
leadership
no no she said she was going to do
corporations and corporation tax she was
going to do National Insurance she
didn't say she was going to bring
forward
um the uh income tax cut by one year she
didn't say she was going to cut she was
going to cut the top rate of tax and
this is the point that in that
leadership contest she was guiding the
markers towards what she was going to do
and when you normally have a budget
there's three elements you have the tax
you have to spend you have the fiscal
framework she did the um tax she still
hasn't done the spend and she hasn't
done the fiscal framework so I think it
was the fact that she went over the
boardwalk she said in the leadership
contest that made it so difficult my
point is that what she was saying
leadership contest was very much making
it clear that she was going to be this
kind of prime minister and it was not
not going to be a situation normal it
wasn't going to be the treasury
Orthodoxy it was going to be sudden and
it was going to be a Brave New World
kind of thing but at this point we're in
a situation now where she could do a
slingshot around the sun and it still
wouldn't be a big enough U-turn to save
her she is going to have to go at some
time and as I said earlier on it's a
matter of when not if and also how
what's the mechanism that the Tory MPS
find to displace that because they need
to they just don't have the way of doing
it yet let's have a look at the
telegrapher Sebastian take us into to
this uh trust clings to power after
axing uh quote many suggesting that he's
simply been a scapegoat yes and I think
if you were quasi-quartang pouring a
stiff drink tonight you might be feeling
a little bit peeved by the situation
because he's actually done everything
Liz trust wanted him to do in this
situation he hasn't gone against her
there's not been any big rounds between
number 10 and number 11. exactly and you
know he's essentially been sacked
because
um the markets didn't believe in the
strategy but it was a strategy that was
made between these two buildings behind
us it wasn't just the Prime Minister who
came up with this but I think the
crucial thing is the point that you
raised earlier um Susie from the times
which is saying that Mr kwatang believes
she hasn't got that much longer left and
I think by putting in Jeremy Hunt it has
bought her some credibility you know
he's from the left of the Tory party
that was a clear decision made to try
and win over moderate MPS he's been
foreign secretary he's been Health
secretary he's been an MP since 2 2005
so he's got a decent track record
although I would say he's never done a
single thing in the treasury he's got no
Financial experience no fiscal
experience
got in government it's not got her very
far is it it's going to prime minister
where's she going next Sebastian up
that question for recruitment agents but
I think but I think the key the key the
key here is that Jeremy Hunt has got
there's this 18 days in theory until
October the 31st when he's got to try
and make these sums add up he's got to
do the media rounds he's got to explain
he's got his work he certainly does just
to end a little bit of support in the
express the headline vulture circling
but the star let us with longer life
than trust Susie yes very quickly this
is basically there's a an excoriating
piece in the economist earlier this week
saying that uh because of when she came
in and then take away the 10 days of
mourning for the Queen the actual amount
of control that Liz truss had over her
government was about seven days which is
the shelf life of the lettuce I would
suggest it's probably worse than that
lettuce carries on quite a long time I
think we're looking at Raw poultry Susie
thank you very much ten you have come to
TV and